so let's say that we have some mystery
substance here and we know that it's a
pure element and we need to figure out
what it is well scientists have a method
and we go into the details or more
details and other videos called mass
sometimes it's known as mass
spectrometry or mass spectroscopy it's a
technique where you could take a sample
of a substance and think about the
various atomic masses of the different
isotopes in that substance and that's
what we have right over here they tell
us the mass spectrum for an average
sample of a pure element is shown below
so let's say it's this pure element so
what this is telling us is this looks
like maybe I don't know let's call this
82 percent of our sample has an atomic
mass of 88 Universal atomic mass units
about this looks like about 7% of our
sample has an atomic mass of 87
Universal atomic mass units it looks
like 10% has an atomic mass of 86
Universal atomic mass units and it looks
like about one percent of our sample has
an atomic mass of 84 Universal atomic
mass units and so from this information
we can try to estimate what the average
atomic mass of this mystery element is
we could calculate it as zero point
eight two times 88 times
88 plus let's call this seven percent so
zero point zero seven times 87 plus ten
percent 0.1 times 86 plus unless he
showed up to 100% this is because it's
89 and then this gets us to 99 so then
another one percent 0.01 times 84 and so
if we were to do this calculation this
is our estimate of the average atomic
mass of this element we could type this
into a calculator and get some number
and then look that up on a periodic
table of elements or we could just try
to estimate it we can see that it's
to be close to 88 because that's where
the highest percentage is we have the
hot when we're taking the weighted
average we have the highest weight right
over there but these other isotopes
these other versions of the element that
have a different number of neutrons
which changes its atomic mass they're
going to bring the average down so our
average atomic mass is going to be a
little bit less than 88 so let's look up
a periodic table of elements what
element here has an atomic mass a little
bit less than 88 well yet reom is eighty
eight point nine one but we know it
can't be that because none of the
isotopes have an atomic mass above 88 so
we can rule out yttrium strontium is
looking pretty good
it's exactly what we predicted a little
bit less than 88 and rubidium is a lot
less than 88 so our even if we were to
do the calculation we could feel
confident we're not going to be as low
as rubidium so I'm feeling very
confident just eyeballing it just
estimating this is going to be a little
bit have an average atomic mass a little
bit less than 88 which tells me that
this is strontium